change lives crvena anja lives change
organizations guy [ __ ] the organization
also might change the world
before coming to the GSB James was he
studied robotics and automation he
worked for BCG in a number of places New
Zealand Australia Chicago he's going to
be doing a summer internship he's gonna
be working with maile at amazon and also
working with a robotics medical device
startup so we're gonna hear from James
and some of his past experiences that
got him to where he is today give it up
for James so when you think of at-risk
youth who do you think of when you hear
statistics like one in five students
will bring a weapon to school before
they graduate or that one in 18 will
have to go before a judge prior to high
school graduation or that one in 20 will
attempt to commit suicide before they
turn 18 which kids do you think of now
it's not uncommon when we hear these
statistics to think that they're somehow
extreme that they impact a part of the
population that we just simply don't
belong to well i'd like to tell you the
story about a chair so just down the
road in palo alto at the west meadows
road crossing there's a white plastic
chair by the railway lines now this
chair was put there by the community so
they could do shifts every single day
until the very last train passes at
midnight to make sure that kids weren't
jumping in front of trains to commit
suicide now this is just one story it's
pretty extreme but this situation was
prompted after four students between the
ages of 13 and 17 committed suicide
there I share the story to highlight how
close to home the issue of troubled
youth can be
this the kids involved in this tragic
story weren't the ones that were
constantly at the counselor's office
they didn't look weird in fact what's
scary is they look just like any other
students in their class and remember
this happened in Palo Alto not halfway
across the country but our own beautiful
effluent backyard and note that the
entire community put that chair there
and it wasn't just concerned parents
that man that chair because irrespective
of whether we are or whether we intend
to be parents or not we will all belong
in communities where there will be kids
and this is why the issue of at-risk
youth is relevant to all of us now I
don't want this talk to be all doom and
gloom for 12 minutes so I want to also
share that the good news is there are
things both big and small that we all
can do actually that you can do to
really change a child's life I want to
share the story of a young boy this boy
grew up with his mother and when he
turned 9 his mother thought it'd be a
good idea for him to spend some time
with his dad who was living overseas now
what this mother and the boy did not
know was that the environment that this
boy was to hidden to with his dad and
with his dad's new wife that it would be
an abuse of one so imagine the situation
we've got a young boy in a new country
he doesn't speak a word of the local
language he's in an abusive environment
with no friends or family to help him
out what's a boy to do he does what he
knows to do which is run away from it
all he runs away from home obviously
doesn't go to school anymore and even
has to steal food in order to survive
cops would catch this boy stealing he'd
be returned back to his family and the
whole vicious cycle would continue that
is until one day a shopkeeper catches
this boy stealing and unlike everyone
else before him the shopkeeper decided
not to call the cops but to call his
friend who also happened to be a social
worker now to cut a very long story
short there is a happy ending this one
phone call meant that this boy was able
to get into a stable home environment
focus on his education and ultimately
become amongst the first in his family
to graduate from college now I share the
story to illustrate the power of one
little thing in being able to change a
child's life in this story it was that
one phone call that started to change
this boy's life now I know about the
power of a little thing in being able to
take a child off the streets to be
standing here in front of you today
because that boy was me and that story
is mine and my life was changed because
of one of these little things now I
acknowledge that this is a big tricky
issue it's a tough problem to solve and
has hooks and societal issues such as
poverty and I also recognize that you
never quite know when these little
things will truly be able to change a
child's life again back to the good news
the good news is there are tons of great
organizations that try and solve this
problem in a big in a far more
systematic way and I just like to
highlight a couple today that I've had
the fortune I've been involved with so
the first is project K so they are a
youth mentoring program based back home
in New Zealand actually very similar to
Big Brothers Big Sisters here in the US
which I'm
many of you are familiar with one hope
United is based in Chicago and when I
was working there I was fortunate enough
to be involved with them to help develop
a program that provides services and
resources to low-income families so they
can provide a stable home environment
for their kids and in fact right now i'm
a board fellow with a great organization
based right here in palo alto name
peninsula bridge now for those of you
that don't know board fellows meant to
help the bridge but meant to help the
organization that they're worth but i
think i create more homework for some my
board members than i do and helping them
but bridge provides great summer
programs are over for for low income for
low resource students so they can be
prepared to graduate from high school
now my own organization isn't quite
ready to be Placid up here well if we
had a screen but I've started working
towards my own organization that looks
after kids not only on these various
critical stages of their life but right
throughout the journey from childhood to
being successful adults why should we do
great work in middle school and pray
that they'll know how to get into the
best high schools and once they graduate
from high school how do we know they can
play this Derek Bolton game to get them
to the best colleges in the world I
could go on and on about working the
space and i encourage you to have those
conversations to reach out to me if
you're interested now I'd like to share
one of my favorite stories of working
with one of these organizations now this
might be seem like a weird question to
be asking right now but who here even
knew that New Zealand has national ice
hockey teams well we do one particular
clean team the New Zealand at a 16-team
now we're not as good as these we're not
as good as the Canadians we're not as
good as the Americans but on this
particular tour we were better than the
Australians and frankly that's all that
really matters
I want to introduce you to a boy who I
was working with at project K that
really wanted to be on the New Zealand
team so meet thirteen-year-old Connor so
Connor came from a troubled family he
was a prolific truant and at risk of
failing every single one of his classes
and I remember having a conversation
with Connor partway through our
mentoring relationship when I was
considering moving to Chicago for work
he said why do you want to go to Chicago
and I started listing off all these
reasons for why I thought Chicago would
be a great place and in hindsight I
realized how little I knew about Chicago
because right at the top of the list was
I thought it'd be refreshing to live in
a city that snowed once in a while
during winter anyway so I didn't think
much of this conversation and as I
alluded to earlier Connor was an avid
ice hockey player and wanted to be on
the national team but unfortunately for
him he was a bit of a shrimp he was tiny
compared to kids his age but we worked
at it took him two practices showed up
two games when his mum couldn't make it
and then the good news came yes he had
made the New Zealand ice hockey team and
again if we had a screen I could show
you how small he was relative to the
rest of his team when I heard the great
news I asked Connor I said may you would
tiny compared to those guys what made
you stick through all the tough
trainings to think that you could make
the team and he said well I heard that
the next tournament was going to be in
Chicago and I knew I wanted to be there
and then I had a bit of one of the those
of you that are parents in here you have
those little cool moments when you you
know your kids pay you a compliment so I
had one of those I said Wow in my head I
thought this kid wants to come halfway
around the world to be with me because I
was that awesome of a mentor and as kids
do he would burst my cool bubble right
after he said well you know I've always
wanted to go to Chicago and Connor
begins listing off all these great
reasons for why he wanted to go to
Chicago and you guessed it at the top of
the list was I thought it'd be fun to
visit a city that snowed a little during
winter so I want to use the story to
basically show how one little innocent
conversation can really help move a
child towards his goal I had that little
conversation with Connor yes it helped
him succeed at his hockey aspirations
but actually more importantly it had
lots of positive impacts throughout his
life that year Connor would pass every
single one of his classes and actually I
just had to call Connor last week to
make sure he was still on track to
graduate from high school and yes we're
still all green there this story really
highlights to me why I wanted to give
this this story sorry highlights to me
why I really wanted to give this talk
today in part it was about raising
awareness of at-risk youth but perhaps
more importantly I want to inspire every
single one of you to do something to
help a child in your life in fact I'd
like you to take a moment right now just
to think through what you can do to help
kids what will be your Connor moment I'm
not going to stand up here and suggest
what's a big thing for you or what's a
little thing we're just be is there are
alumni in here they're successful
professionals in here you're all doing
great things and we'll go on to do even
bigger things if you want to donate to
an organization well I think my
peninsula bridge board and fellow our
board members and directors wouldn't
forgive me if I didn't give them a bed
of Prague so Peninsula bridge dog people
or it could be something as small as
calling your niece or nephew that you
haven't spoken to in a while I know that
over the last 12 minutes that I've been
rambling up here something has come up
in your mind about what you can do to
help kids in your life the
she knows what are you waiting for thank
you